welcome to GQ rules I'm Adam a port this
is GQ creative director Jim more gym a
year ago in GQ rules we told guys like
all the style essentials how to do the
perfect I not how suit should fit all
the rules this time around then somehow
to break how to break the rules how to
find your own personal style and over
the next 30 days we'll have 30 high def
videos I doubt not just two of us got a
lot of guess who we got well we got a
lot of designers actually okay I start
off with Michael bash I made this whole
classic American thing cool again he's
gonna show you four ways to put a suit
together then you're gonna have tom
brown on brown who's gonna do the
sockless think he's gonna put this talk
business out of business we got Scott
sternberg from band of outsiders he's
gonna show you how to work boat I'm you
can wear one I can wear we're gonna show
you how to wear one pod that's not all
we go really who do we have lower hits
it's mr. going Orion GQ style guy oh hi
Adam I'm sorry to interrupt your reading
Glen I've got a few questions for you
yes the first thing where are we this is
Jake crew world head point there's a
j.crew world headquarters maybe I could
win something you could wind up in and
so can you if you sign up for GQ rules
you have a chance to win a
ten-thousand-dollar j.crew wardrobe
surely you mean a one-thousand-dollar no
no I'm talking ten thousand ten grand 10
grand but that's not all you get you get
a chance to come to New York for a GQ
photoshoot to be in the magazine if you
really alright so gun if you want to win
the sweepstakes the trip to New York you
want to watch 30 videos over the next 30
days what do you do where do you go just
sign up obvious you sign up you sign up
at GQ com go now watch DQ rules learn
from it live it now
over the next 30 days watch 30 videos on
GQ rules learn to find your own personal
style for it kuz women and break them